and this leads us into the the top
story on a slow tuesday but it's still
a significant story on any tuesday
jj watts seriously considering the
cleveland browns this from mary kay
cabot of the cleveland plain dealer now
there's two ways to look at this
one way is jj watt is firing a warning
shot to any other team that may be
seriously interested
that it may be time to make a move even
if you don't know what the salary cap's
going to be
i'm thinking about the browns hello is
this thing on
is there anyone else out there because
we're not hearing any other teams
rushing
because of the salary cap the browns
could pull it off
because they've got the cap space the
other side of it too peter
and this brings us back to the packers i
said this last night on pftpm
it reminds me at a lower level
the legitimacy that this move would give
the browns it reminds me of reggie white
choosing the green bay packers in 93
not that jj watt is currently anywhere
close to white at his prime
but it it this doesn't happen for the
browns
there isn't a free agent that a lot of
teams are like oh we're interested in
him and that guy
even seriously considers the browns when
does that ever happen when does it ever
happen that a
a a a guy of this stature
is even linked to the browns so even if
they don't get him
just the fact that they're at the table
that's got to be encouraging for
cleveland browns fans
well mike i you know let's just let's
talk a little bit about
history here because i think it's
important
um when you consider a guy like reggie
white
and a guy like jj watt remember think
back
to 1993 when reggie white was on the
market
okay that's 28 years ago and that was
one of the first long stories
big stories i ever did for sports
illustrated i went
on the trip on the plane with jimmy
sexton the agent
reggie white uh and harry galbraith who
was a guard at the time but who was also
a jimmy sexton client uh who was taking
some of these trips
and it was really interesting the trip
to cleveland
and how the browns went all out bill
belichick was
was there at a dinner with a bunch of
players and
reggie white and sexton and it was real
wooing okay now last year in this year
there
there can be no such wooing obviously
because of the pandemic
but i think there's a couple of similar
things
number one this would be even though the
browns
you know were on the verge of really
doing something great
a month ago you know and and
accomplished more than any of us thought
they would
by winning a road playoff game and then
giving kansas city all it wanted
you know in the next round of the
playoffs i think
the browns might be ready and we all can
see it
to take that next step when they got
when they
wooed reggie white 28 years ago that was
a team that a year
later was actually going to make the
playoffs so i think in cleveland
they are looking at this with the other
teams in the division
not being bulletproof anymore you know
they're looking at this as hey listen
this could be
our time and to get a guy like jj watt
to give you i think
two really good years plus mike think of
it
who's the leader of the browns on
defense right now you know
there isn't really one guy who you would
say
is is the guy on demons whereas you know
you got jarvis landry on offense you got
mayfield
you know you've got guys on offense that
really kind of fill that bill
and i think watt could help in that way
as well
and you know it's funny you talk about
the browns trying to get reggie white
93 that means if he had chosen the
browns the year that he otherwise won a
super bowl with the packers
would have been his first year with the
baltimore ravens in 96
so alternate universe fun as it relates
to where reggie white could have ended
up and what city he could have been in
not because of his own choosing but
because art model chose to move the team
there
but i think the other sign is in this
weird kind of offseason where a lot of
veterans who thought they were safe will
find themselves looking for work
and a lot of free agents who thought
they were going to break the bank will
find themselves taking one-year deals
wherever they can get them
the browns will be potentially in
position
to attract multiple of these
recognizable names with gas in the tank
who can come in
and help and the challenge is
where do you stop how many can you
really fit how far do you go okay we
want jj what
if you don't get him okay we want this
guy how many can we get
when do we have to say enough's enough
or we're gonna get ourselves into a cap
problem
good problem to have if you're the
browns because where they are right now
you add two or three guys it doesn't
take many to push you to the next level
especially when you get odell beckham jr
back assuming he's healthy
but you add a couple of guys who can
come in make a difference
and jj watt makes a difference on the
field and off the field great member of
the community
sell a ton of jerseys 99 jersey
in brown and white or orange or whatever
that that will be a big item even though
folks know it's a short time
relationship between
the browns and jj watt i it's it's just
fascinating to think
that this browns team that has been
downtrodden for so long is a player now
that's the
big takeaway i have from that even if
they're being used by jj watt as
leverage to get the steelers to
figure their stuff out quickly so they
don't have to deal with jj watt
twice per year and compete with him
otherwise every week of the year in the
division
the fact that the browns can even be
used as that that
candidate to be the leverage item with a
straight face
is is a sign that the browns are here
whether they stay or not we'll see that
applies to any team we don't know
time will tell but at least they're here
something they haven't been in a very
long
mike let me ask you this question
because i'm curious about what you would
think of this
i have heard that jj watt uh
out of out of great respect to
his brother tj might not want to go to
pittsburgh
and i've heard that i don't know how
true it is because obviously i have not
talked to watt himself
but one of the things that interests me
about that is
you know that when jj watts shows up in
a place
especially if you're still doing things
virtually
you know who's the one guy who everybody
is going to ask to interview
you know all on many many occasions
j.j watt he's a he's a fountain he's
you know he's he's always been sort of
team spokesman
and maybe he tells whoever he signs with
i don't want that role anymore
you know i i don't that that's not me
that shouldn't be me i don't know
but i do think that jj walking into a
locker room to some degree
is sucking the air out of the room so i
think that is
one thing to watch for and you tell me
if you think that might be even a little
bit of a factor
let me agree with you and take it in a
slightly different direction
tj watt is entering the final year of
his contract with the steelers 10
million in his option
season as a result of being a
first-round pick he doesn't have a
long-term deal yet
and if jj watt would sign a two-year
deal with the steelers
that complicates things for tj watts
long-term contract
because does he walk away after next
year
does he do this does the steelers do the
steelers excuse me think that they can
squeeze tj to take a little bit less so
he can keep playing with his brother
like it just complicates the negotiation
if jj is part of the team whereas tj can
just focus on
getting what he already deserves but
hasn't gotten yet from the steelers
after four seasons
of great performances what are they
going to do going into this year
would they franchise tag him next year
where's that relationship and i think
that's a complicating factor
in addition to the possibility of
jj watt as you said suck in the air out
of the room and all of a sudden nobody
wants to talk to tj and everybody wants
to talk to jj and he overshadows his
younger brother
just the fact that jj's made his money
and
tj's in position to make his and having
jj on the team could complicate that
i think that's another reason to not do
it now is that a reason to stay in the
division
i think that's a reason to join the
packers like you said all things equal
he goes to the packers the and i'm
fascinated by the possibility of jj and
tj
watt on opposite ends of the brown
steelers rivalry
but i don't i don't know that that's
ideal for them
unless they truly can compartmentalize
their
their relationship as brothers with
their relationship as competitors
i think that's a really good point i the
one other team
in here that could be in here i think
that
that you know obviously jj watt
wants to play with a team that can win a
super bowl
next year or the year after so i think
really there's there's two teams that
you know we haven't talked about a lot
or maybe you have but
i haven't heard talked about a lot
they've been mentioned but tennessee and
buffalo
and i think both of those teams quite
honestly
could contend to play deep very deep
into the season next year
you know because of all the
complementary parts they have all over
the roster
but you know mike i'm not sure that
cleveland
is just a stalking horse if indeed
they're seriously involved
and that is because you know teams in
the nfl
take a jump all the time
and if you look at that roster and look
and see how many high draft choices
they have on their team how many really
good players they have on their team
who are on the verge of really doing
something great
i could see him saying i can see the
browns winning
especially because look the steelers
are no lock to to own that division
and you know i think the ravens probably
entering next year at least to me
would be i would think they would be the
presumptive favorite
over pittsburgh and i think some people
would say let's give it to cleveland so
cleveland is definitely in that race
the the one other thing i would say
though is
it's really really tough in the afc
because probably you're going to have to
get by and there's a good chance on the
road
kansas city even next year i'm not
trying to be
you know put the ball too far down the
field this early but
i have to think that of all the 32 teams
in the nfl if you had to ask me
give me one team as the favorite for
home field in
its conference in 2021
i'd say kansas city again for the fourth
consecutive year
you know you're touching on a good point
as it relates to trying to figure out
now if you're jj what which horse you're
going to climb on to
because there are so many factors
so many variables so much stuff still to
be determined he signs a contract today
it's before the potential purge of
veterans for cap reasons it's before
free agency where you can maybe go out
and get some bargain basement level
veterans that help make you better it's
before the draft even happens
for crying out loud and all you can do
miles simmons and i last night on pftpm
were talking about this
it's a pass fail analysis there are
teams that are above the line
and teams that are below the line the
browns are above the line the titans who
john robinson the gm yesterday he's
either keeping his
cards close to the vest or he's really
interested or not i mean he said what
gm's
have to say which is basically nothing
but they could be interested the bills
like that that would make sense
those are all teams on the right side of
the line they're in contention
and beyond that you have no idea no one
does how the dominoes are going to fall
one injury changes everything and we
know the injuries happen all the time we
spend
from february until september
prognosticating about the season to come
it it all falls apart once guys start
getting injured and everything
changes and and that's the thing if
you're jj watt
and you don't have a crystal ball all
you can do is pick one of the teams
that reasonably seems to be in position
to contend
and everything after that is yet to be
written here's the question
you know as you spoke about that i kept
thinking to myself
what would happen if andy reid said to
brett veach this week
hey listen let's carve out something
somehow there whatever 20 million over
the projected cap
and they would have to probably have
some ugly decisions
um they would probably have to make some
ugly decisions that would hurt
their team but just imagine if they saw
we want one more piece on that defensive
front
and they could get jj watt and they told
watt listen sign a three-year deal
have the number be very small
uh in your first year and
you know help us out on the contract and
you come in
and you know we'll guarantee it but but
we're going to backload this
and basically mike it i i honestly think
if i'm jj watt
and i want to win a super bowl and i
don't know how many years i'm gonna play
i'm serious i i am pushing either the
packers
or the or the chiefs i'm pushing the two
teams
this year that one home field because
look
honestly you can't look at tampa bay and
think
there's there could be anything serious
there
because tampa bay is on record is saying
we're signing everybody
and once they start throwing guys
overboard
to add different guys all of a sudden
the chemistry inside the team everybody
said
hey wait a second and domican sue wants
to come back another year
you brought in jj watt i thought we were
a family and that's a naive thing to say
obviously but that is what i could see
happening so
i'm just eliminating the bucks right now
do you make it a good point
i don't think but hang on a second i
don't think that's a naive thing to say
peter because the vibes coming from the
box over the past week
have been consistent with that so if
they don't behave that way
right they're creating a problem because
they've already said they've already
written the checks to keep the guys at
least they've done it that's the
verbally
that's the point if they scroll these
guys over they are going to have trouble
you can't do it
i agree you can't jj watt can't really
be on tampa bay's list
not that he would be on their list
anyway i mean
especially if they bring shaq barrett
back if they have barrett
and jpp and then they have at least one
of the two guys in the middle
you know vida vey or i mean vita vase
coming back you know or
or or in dominican sioux it's hard to
imagine
that they would spend money on jj watts
so that's why i would eliminate him
but anyway the two teams that if if if i
were him and i was
really focusing on trying to win in the
next couple of years
those are the two teams i would i tried
them i i'd go to the general managers of
each thing and just say
if you've got interest we will be very
friendly contractually
now that's not a tom condon way mike tom
condon is a is an
excellent excellent agent obviously he's
been doing it forever
and he's not going to give away any of
his leverage but
i you know i i think this might be a
case
where jj watts says to his agent hey
listen i don't really care what the
money is
get me to green bay or get me wherever
it is that he really wants to go
yeah i mean the best agents make their
clients happy and meet their
expectations and if watt says this is
what i want he's made his money
he can go wherever he wants to go and
and and then it becomes a question of
especially
in green bay what are they willing to do
to enhance their short term chances
right
last year first round pick plus a fourth
round pick used to get a backup
quarterback who didn't play at all
in 2020 could have been useful in the
nfc championship against the buccaneers
what will they do and they do have their
own issues as well
aaron jones running back becoming a free
agent corey linsley center becoming a
free agent other guys
lesser in value to the team what are we
going to do with them well we're going
to get rid of some veterans are we going
to have
money available how's this going to work
but
they'd have to at least i think show
some interest in working something out
some interest in adding a guy like jj
watt to the team
if they believe it will make them better
that's the other side of this though
given his age given his injury history
will you have
general managers on contending teams say
let's not get caught up in this let's
not
let's not fall victim to the land rush
for a guy
great question we don't have this
certainty is really going to make a
difference it's going to make a
a buzz we're going to sell a lot of
jerseys people are going to care about
us
but is it really going to make a
difference for us in december january
and hopefully february
it that's the question that everybody
has to ask to me it's very similar to
carson wentz
you know you look at jj watt of four and
five years ago
and and even a couple of years ago he
had a very good year
um and and it's the same thing look at
carson wentz in 2017
and he'd say man look at him boy if if
he can just do that and
and that is the big issue if you're a
general manager in this case
just one second on chris ballard of the
indianapolis colts
you not only have to look at the fact
that you need a long-term quarterback
and carson wentz is very young and three
years ago he was a top five quarterback
in the league
you not only have to look at that you
have to look at
what is he now and what will he be for
the next seven or eight years
and you have to then value that what is
that worth
that's why you know howie roseman is
unable to make a trade right now because
his value of carson wentz is so much
different
and that's why i think when you look at
jj watt it's got to be somebody
who truly believes in jj wad and who if
you for instance
will look at pro football focus and you
will look at what he did last year
jj watt was a top 10 when he played
interior last year not edge but when he
played interior
he was a top 10 top 10 player at his
position the defensive interior
in the nfl and so if you look at that
and you believe
that you're going to get 12 or 13 games
out of them
and you believe that you can disrupt
offenses from the inside and not just
from the outside
you go after j.j watt and you go after
him hard
i wonder how much the
courtship and ultimate performance of
jadavian clowney last year
in tennessee after multiple teams
they're different people though
i know i know but when you have
the the decision makers in the room and
somebody's gonna be the naysayer
that's gonna be the example they point
to with these older guys with injury
history
money in a year of a depressed salary
cap
you know should we do it maybe we
shouldn't do it maybe we should learn
from what happened with the titans and
then maybe somebody else is like oh i
don't want to be in a position where
joe's going to here's the difference
mike if jj gets injured in october
why did the atlanta falcons not resign
vic beasley
because they thought he didn't love
football okay
why was it so hard for davey and connie
to get a
long term contract somewhere because
teams are not convinced that he's going
to work hard in the off season that he's
going to be
fully totally dedicated to be a great
football player
he is a great football player often okay
but
i don't think he's one of those i'd want
to pay 20 million a year to over
on a five-year deal and but i think wad
is different
you never have to work you have to worry
about injury with what without any
question
you don't have to worry about any other
thing
than injury hey and that's a big deal
don't get me wrong
but you don't have to worry about desire
or what they really want out of life
j.j watt wants to be the greatest
football player he can be
that's his whole goal that's what drives
them every day
so i i wouldn't be i really wouldn't
compare him to
those other guys the uh
the other teams that uh are in the mix
or at least would like to be in the mix
based upon
the opinions of their players just a
couple of who
who have gone public deandre hopkins
teammate of watts
with the houston texans takes to
instagram
to court jj watt with a great photoshop
i mean that's a great one that one
fooled me i'm thinking when did the
texans wear black jerseys with red
numbers no that's a photoshop of
what in the cardinals uniform and stefan
diggs also would like to get jj
even with the larry wilson patch on it
mike
yes the eight ball patch i it's very
well done
and uh buffalo bills would like to get
jj water at least stefan diggs would
just hear me out real quick
big fella uh these aren't the people who
make the decisions obviously but this
just adds to the intrigue because
players in today's age can
can go public worldwide anytime they
want to express
their opinions and that may frustrate
the people who have their fingers on the
purse strings because it creates
expectations they may not fulfill
but we'll see how that plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports